so psyched to have this man on the
program the season two finale of keenan
airs monday january 31st with
back-to-back episodes at 8 and 8 30 p.m
on nbc and then it'll air the next day
right here on peacock he plays keenan's
um
live uh pardon me he plays keenan's
living father-in-law and he provides
shocking wisdom between martinis on this
program the legendary don johnson here
on the rich eisen show how are you don
i'm good rich how are you doing i'm
better for talking to you i'm not going
to lie i'm wrong
you're
very nice what is the what what's the
thing people bring up to you the most
when they run into you dawn you know
what are they doing oh god i mean what
do you know it's it
it's either
you know it's either the bags over the
heads in the quentin tarantino movie and
django or it's harley davidson the
marlboro man or it's eastbound it down
or it's uh knives out or you know i get
it's all over the place and yes more
recently um
uh with keenan
and uh we're getting some love over
there i like it i love it keenan is one
of the funniest guys ever in fact he and
he's also one of the
he's a just a stand-up guy i mean we get
each other and um
you know he gets it he's uh he's smart
and funny and and he's got your back and
uh yeah we're hooked up over there i
know and it's a funny program again uh
with the season finale airing monday on
the 31st back-to-back episodes um and
then the next day right here on peacock
so what what uh what drew you to doing
that with keenan just
what drove you well uh in my i'm friends
with uh lauren michaels uh and um uh i
did
i was doing
a table read with with with him for a
movie
and um it had nothing to do with keenan
and then
the movie didn't the movie fell through
about but about three months later
lauren called me and said read this i
want to
see if you want to do anything you may
not
so i read it and i love kenan and i love
the premise of the show and um
you know it's like um um
and the character is completely
different than anything i've ever played
so it was um
it was uh yeah okay let's get it on how
did you run into meeting lauren
how long ago i met lauren you know uh
back before dirk was
uh
you know he's just we've just been in
each other's lives for
40 years you know i think i met
i think when i was still a struggling
actor i met
lauren at duke's
restaurant in in la where we all used to
go for with
to cure our hangovers out down the beach
yeah right yeah and um and so that's
where i met lauren the first time and um
and then you know it's just we've been
in each other's lives ever since don
johnson here on the rich eisen show
what's your sports team what do you have
anything
oh man i got a little schizophrenia
going on over here you know i got i have
sons i have opinions okay and they have
teams okay so i sort of have to take
them i i'm a kansas city chiefs fan
and um
uh and i feel good about our chances
uh this uh this weekend and my youngest
son is a rams fan and my uh oldest or
not my oldest but my the next one up
is um is a green base man so it was a
little bit of heartbreak and a little
bit of uh thrill and kill for the other
for us for me and my other son yeah so i
mean this weekend was insane this was
one of the greatest football weekends uh
of all time it's the greatest game i've
ever seen
just not even gonna lie
it was true have you ever been to any
super bowls don have you ever
i've been to several super bowls um
you know the the i've been to a couple
one and one in new orleans and and one
um
oh my gosh uh
you know i can't remember i've been to
about three or four super bowls my
problem is they're a little better now
my problem is in the old days they were
about six hours long
and uh and um you know you you could
probably go play 18 holes and still come
back and catch the fourth quarter
you know and um but but now it's gotten
a little better so the show's a little a
little tighter and stuff like that so if
you're at the game and you're watching
the game you're not you know you're not
waiting around forever for um
uh for snoop dogg and dre to finish with
their
show how is your golf game don johnson
how is your golf game
it's a little it's a little shaky right
now but uh you know given the right
number of strokes i could probably beat
you okay i'll take that um so how'd you
get involved in tin cup how'd that one
go about from you back in the day
you know something i was the only actor
in town with a name that could play golf
there's a lot of actors that say they
can play golf right there's not a lot
that look like they can play golf and
that and i'm not a great golfer but i
look like a great golfer
okay so you were you you versus costner
real time
played together heads up before um uh
you know it's like
you know i on any given day i i i i can
beat him usually
you know seven out of ten times but he's
got game you know kevin's an athlete
he's
really good he's kevin costner so uh so
and you're don johnson though so did you
did you
take any la you needed no lessons no no
golf coach at all for tin cup
well that's part of what's wrong with my
game is that
as a celebrity you get lessons from
everybody
you know if you're playing in a pro-am
and there's 10 pros you're going to get
a lesson from all 10 of those bros
and of course you can't remember them
and uh holding a swing thought is uh is
well you can just forget that because
you know you got uh well at the time i
had payne stewart
and um uh uh phil mickelson and um
uh peter costas and about four others in
my head
so
really like like what giving you tips uh
or
just in general or just not for the
movie yeah just give him he's just
giving me swing thoughts and peter
costas was actually he he was the first
one i was trying to i was picking the
ball off the ground
i wasn't really trapping it you know i
was sort of picking it and he was the
first one to notice it and you know you
got to be a pretty damn good athlete to
pick the ball off the ground and still
make it dance
and
um and
he looked at me and he said dude he says
you're working really hard let me help
you out here
so
he taught me about the physics of golf i
went oh
oh yeah that's a lot easier yeah hit
down on it and all that business so so
tin cup actually improved your game is
what you're saying john johnson oh my
god yeah when i when i went out to make
the movie i was about a
i don't know
maybe a 10
um and by the time i finished making the
movie i was a three
a good
solid legitimate consistent three all
right so what's the best round you've
had and and where what do you got for me
on that fun you got something i played
uh
a scratch round in aspen
um
that was that was pretty good and my but
the the first time i broke 80
was at augusta
okay now come on
really i'm not kidding yeah
from the tips too right or what no not
from the tips not for the pro from the
tips or from where i don't know from no
no no no that is
20 20 somewhat 30 years ago it was from
the tip believe me i was down i was
making a movie down there uh called
paradise and i actually saw one of the
craziest things i've ever seen okay one
of the pros that i was playing with
um stepped up on a par three we're
playing uh those those those uh tracks
there are cannot island and you know
around there and
and uh he
teased it up
hits the ball sculled it
it skipped across the lake
like like you were trying to kill a coot
and uh hit the side of the
finally
curled around hit the side of the bank
went about 20 or 30 feet up in the air
fell down rolled all the way around the
green and dropped in the cup
that's a one there's no pictures on the
scorecard there's no pictures on the
scorecard right that's a one that's a
hate it's a hateful game i think that's
one way to put it but so okay this is
pre-tigerizing the course when you're
out there then um and so you're you're
at augusta first round you ever break
80s at augusta national that is insane
yeah
oh my god that was quite a day i i shot
a 78 that day wow yeah tell me you have
the card still don you got the card
still uh i yeah i have it somewhere i
can't i don't know where i put it but
it's around somewhere man you've got
enough stuff so what it what is in your
man cave what do you have do you have
anything from your history from your
from your
you know i don't keep a lot of showbiz
memorabilia but i have you know there's
a few things there's you know some
photos of
when i did um
the uh inauguration i put together this
little band with that included bob dylan
and
steve stills and uh and the band and uh
garth and all those guys
and so i have a couple of photos of you
know friends and stuff there's some
photos of me and cheats and i've got
guitars
all over the house um
i don't play them much anymore but my
boys play
and um
yeah you know it's just uh uh i i never
i i always got uncomfortable when i
walked into some celebrities house and
he had all these
you know uh photos and posters and you
know that's just surrounded by this uh
uh
you know uh this
shrine to the to the ego and stuff like
and also because i have kids i don't
want my kids to live in a museum right
you know
so i i just vowed to say okay i'm not
going to keep anything around here that
says who daddy is you know have your
kids ever seen an episode of miami vice
oh yeah well that pretty much you know
that's pretty much a required viewing
well there's that whether you're mike
whether you're my kid or not okay that's
no that's true that's true um do you
have any any of the garb from back in
the day do you have any miami vice
suits do you have anything from that do
you want me to send you over some swag
um
well first of all um i'll be honest with
you don yes
yes
i do
there is an eye in rich and eisen okay
there's none in don or johnson so
yes
i would take that you know i don't think
i'd fit in it you know but
i don't know i i i you know i don't keep
that stuff around here but for you i'll
bet i could find it come on now so uh
just what a suit a shirt what do you got
i i mean i'll tell you well i don't know
i'll have to go into the archives and
see what's there there might just be a
piece of alligator i don't know
did you did you have any choice in what
you could wear back in the day because
you don't you do know you created an
entire fashion movement on that program
right don
yeah i mean we had um it was a unique
time because we had um
uh i had this fantastic costumer named
jody tillen and we sent her to
we sent her to milan
to
literally take the clothes off of them
the model's back
from like uh um
um
versace and armani and uh terry mugler
most of these most of these designers we
we made their business because they were
they were hot you know cutting edge
designers that no one was really paying
much attention to but we
we loved that that that fashion and that
that kind of style and then the the
personalization of it was because you
know with the sleeves rolled up and the
no socks and no belts and you know
t-shirts and
and linen jackets and pants and all that
stuff that i mean that was just a
function that it was so damn hot down
there
that
you know i kept trying to take clothes
off so first went to socks and then went
the belt and
you know it was on nbc and if it hadn't
been a network i might have kept taking
things off
so that so it did the sleeves rolled up
was more of a function than anything
else
there wasn't a choice yeah
yeah foreign follows function
and um
uh uh it was just it was
easier cooler and
and it kind of looked good so i said oh
all right i'll go with that well uh uh
i'm uh 54 in italian um
and um
so
we'll see what happens here okay
whatever you got um a 54 that's about it
don um and
other than that i greatly appreciate the
call and i look forward to seeing the
kenan finale
yeah me too and i look forward to uh
some uh big games and listen make sure
all your uh fans and friends out there
tune in to keenan it's worth it man it's
uh it's a good show and it's uh it it'll
leave you feeling good and feeling good
about yourself and
and you'll be doing such a great service
for my for my kids
and that's back-to-back episodes for the
finale it's starting at eight o'clock on
nbc and then right here on peacock the
episodes air the next day look i know
you don't do this sort of stuff often
but uh whenever you want to promote
anything or if not i'd love to have you
back don it's a pleasure oh you're so
nice rich i really enjoyed it and thanks
for having me thank you very much um and
even honestly i'll have you back even if
there's nothing in your closet for me i
understand
you just keep just keep your eyes on the
mail we'll figure it out
love it thank you don johnson you take
care
okay guys all right there's don johnson
everybody right here on twitter and
instagram at don johnson
i jewish goodbye to him because i don't
want to say goodbye to him
no he seems like a fun hang
dude
can you imagine something comes in the
middle and something like that can you
imagine
it's like a white gucci sport jacket you
know what you know what it i would
destroy it just by putting it on
these things don't look good on me they
just like you know like you know what i
mean like on him it's like frame it
maybe he'll sign it and frame it no i
would wear it you wouldn't wear it no
excuse me wear it
excuse me if
there is a miami vice jacket in his
closet and he's like screw it
screw it i don't need anymore but uh you
know rich asked
it'll be fun i'll send it
and
you wouldn't try it on
take a picture wear it out
while wearing it out isn't must
absolutely i'd wear it out i mean
according to wikipedia he's 511 he's our
size it's i'm six foot so it should fit
that's correct
one more thing
i would i would
intermittently fast to fit in just to
make sure that it fits yes
and then go out to dinner i went on the
boat in that yes craig's in the in
full miami vice and say this is don
johnson's i'm wearing it will you would
you wear the pink t-shirt underneath
whatever okay
yeah you got to wear like the v-neck
this is what are you talking to roll the
sleeves up
the fact that you say you wouldn't do
that that you'd rather just hang it
somewhere and frame it here's the
problem
i would be afraid of spilling marinara
sauce on it you know and you know
you know
the uh the guest host of this show the
thursday and friday after the super bowl
will attest
i am a human drop cloth
yeah my clothes are my clothes are drop
cloths okay i'm just saying it's chicken
parm and then uh
does marinara come out of 35 year old
armani it doesn't come out of
three-year-old armani it doesn't come
out of any harmony i would i would i
would here's what i would do i would
show up
i would show up wearing the suit would
you would you notify the paparazzi
beforehand of course i'd call tmz yo of
course
oh really you're here oh hi oh hi hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here